ja ich habe locken genauso wie cory von
tur tur händel und darauf reagiere ich
auch heute gemeinsam mal wieder mit euch
meine lieben freunde und zwar zum
letzten mal vor meiner pause ab morgen
mache ich ein bis zwei wochen pause von
youtube laden nichts hochpreis ist
traurig eigentlich können sich alle
glücklich schätzen dass ich mal ein
bisschen weg bin
die genauen gründe für meine kurze
social media pause erfahrt ihr morgen
video also schaltet dann auf jeden fall
ein allerdings habt ihr auf dieses
heutige video hier drauf geklickt weil
ich auf der tenne reagiere das machen
wir jetzt auch stellt euch vor da steht
ein super lecker veganer bürger aber er
sagt dass brokkoli und sellerie besser
für euch sind weil sie euch alles geben
was ihr wollt und brach
ganz kurz recap das hier ist ja ich
glaube die kennt mittlerweile jeder wäre
cool wenn es gar nicht mehr kennen
lernen würde und von chefs eigentlich
mit harry zusammen hat allerdings gerade
ein date mit corey keiner weiß warum sie
sich dafür ein spieler hat allerdings
vergleicht sie die ganzen gerade auch
mit selleriesalat und veganen bürgern
sie hat sich also entschieden also das
ist harry und das ist corrie
wo bin ich dann aber ich brauche diesen
bürgern ok streicht burger und fritten
verhält sich an ihrer diät später ist
sie sagt wirklich da ich jetzt gerade
leider genauso aussehen wie korrigiert
sie mir wahrscheinlich auch zu sagen
falls doch nicht von chaska ist auf
instagram laserdrucker oder gerne vorbei
programm neues foto hochgeladen mit
lukas aus dem urlaub könnt ihr euch ja
ein herz raste ich hab dich wird zwar
liegen die beiden
ich habe ihm gesagt dass ich mich
geschmeichelt fühle und ihnen nicht übel
nehmen dass es versucht weil ich es
genauso gemacht hat
francesca und corey passen die ziemlich
gut zusammen
so von der art
beides so
the girls ja ich bin gespannt was er
jetzt sagt also ich würde dir auf jeden
fall eine ansage machen weil allein dass
sie sich für dieses date entschieden hat
wird mir
persönlich
den strich gehen habt ihr geknutscht
natürlich nicht unbedingt selber bei mir
der liebe klappt gar nichts
aber bei denen dahin schau da hier alle
haare stellt wie hoch er hier darf ich
keine ich war so angespannt und bin
total glücklich dass wir die situation
gemeistert haben wir sind echte streber
was denkt ist für ihn wärst du nur eine
trophäe
ja
wichtig dabei allerdings dass corey für
francesca auch nur die trophäe und jetzt
ist sie mit einem rugby zusammen harry
und franchise gehabt mit dem date
debakel abgeschlossen hast du kurzzeit
wohingegen auch ganz kurz an alle die
neu mit dabei sind das ins klo edi wird
auch von uns auch öfter die lampe
genannt weil sie hat nicht so die
hellste ist muss man einfach ganz klar
sagen und so lampe chloe steht
eigentlich auf cory der halt gerade das
date mit francesca hatte jetzt hat
francesca hat das date eingewilligt
actori am korb gegeben und laut bernkopf
und corey wandels das war echt gemein
von dir richte ich dachte ich könnte dir
vertrauen wichtig ich wollte dir nur
sagen dass ich nicht mehr mit ihr reden
möchte ich
schöner blick franny wir haben so
spitzname füreinander
das ist so unser ding ich nenne sie ein
stadtmensch es gerade nicht sie franny
sie nennt mich anstatt laser luca luca
luka wir sind so so sind wir du kannst
corian machen wie du willst
ich weiß du stehst auf harry und machst
das nur weil ich die ja ja ich denke die
jagd und hatten sogar teile ich sehe
hier die cinema de war wahrscheinlich
was einfach zufall gar nichts ich hätte
an ihrer stelle zumindest einmal ganz
kurz
schön wie du da gerade league scales
derwisch menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abgestoßen ich an francesca stelle hätte
ihr zumindest mal gesagt hey ich war auf
den date einfach nur um eine beziehung
mit harry zu testen und ich habe weder
mit ihm rumgeknutscht noch herr ok
geflirtet haben sie schon
und dass sie sich im ersten moment auch
für dieses date entschieden hat obwohl
sie mit liebe freude dass mit harry
zusammen es war auch ein bisschen
komisch also francesca du bist echt
crazy feiertag im paradies und der ärger
von gestern ist längst vergessen
okay das war schön ich bin sauer auf 7
perfekt der ärger ist vergessen an der
stelle das muss man noch mal ganz klar
rausstellen ich habe eine nacht drüber
geschlafen und ich versuche
verständnisvoll zu sein denn
aber das fällt mir sehr schwer
verständlicher weise für eine liebe miss
lampe ich kann das wirklich voll und
ganz nachvollziehen man muss einfach
überlegen die beiden sind befreundet
glory und francesca francesca hat sogar
noch einen freund geht allerdings mit
dem auf ein date denen glory days das
geht nicht klar
franny wir sind zwar so das geht nicht
klar
das sage ich dir so freundschaftlich
aber wenn man mehr aus der freundschaft
werden sollte wenn box in diesem
workshop lernen wir wie viel stärke in
uns und in unserer gemeinschaft als
schwestern
neuer workshop
dürften jetzt plötzlich eine lektion in
sachen weiblicher einigkeit ist genau
was diese zwei brauchen heute geht es um
die schönheit von unique user von
unique user
wenn man liest ja lipusch
tu's nicht besser hat sich an der würde
nicht ja das musst du vielleicht näher
erläutern schon einige kennen nicht mal
die nummer von 9 11
warum ganz kurz
mal wieder aus meinem gehirn warum haben
wir überall auf der welt in allen
ländern eine andere nummer für den
rettungsdienst also da ist es 911
polizei und baut es 1 1 0
es ist in spanien ist es wieder
irgendwie anders warum habt ihr nicht
einfach alle 9
ich hab die nummer vergessen kann muss
sagen dass dir du wirst heute huldigen
wir unsere heiligen weiblichkeit okay
bitte was wieso seid ihr da alle jetzt
so
die verholt ich teure weiblichkeit geht
damit raus in die welt herr ich bin eine
frau
und
warum finden die das jetzt so komisch
brauchen wir dafür grünes licht warte
grünes licht warum welche negativen
dinge habe er über
[Musik]
wo bin ich hier gelandet als nächstes
schaffte
entnimmt die pinsel und meister floss
dieses bild soll euch an eure stärke
macht und weiblichkeit erinnern
ich bin gespannt was da man die spannung
ist unerträglich
meine juni wird durch ein einhorn
symbolisieren
[Musik]
du hast die aufgabe verstanden
wie heißt sie noch mal
ich kann mir den
ich wette franz bild strotzt vor anmut
[Musik]
das ist ich glaube ich will dich doch
nicht kennenlernen nach diesem workshop
will ich mich den menschen die mich
mögen endlich öffnen es ist halt alles
zusammen zu bringen
meine größte liebe also um einen sohn
und mein neuer schwarm mainz schwamm
mein yoopress
auf englisch nicht wusste ich mein
englischlehrer 1834 in italien
wundervoll sind frauen
ja wir sind stark und wir sollten besser
zusammengehalten gericht mir war klar
dass das auch noch kommt das ist logisch
ja meine lieben freunde das war der
workshop und das war auch das ende der
heutigen reaction von mir auf tour hände
wenn es euch gefallen hat das gern einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
morgen kommt noch mal ein kurzes video
auf einem kanal wo ich euch ein bisschen
erklären warum ich pause mache mir wird
es gerade ehrlich gesagt alles ein
bisschen zu viel aber das erfahrt ihr
alles im morgigen video dann jetzt
befinden uns allerdings auch eine art
des heutigen videos und wenn ihr noch
kein abonnent von einem kanal sondern
klickt hier oben auf den smiley drauf
wenn ihr noch keinen merchandise vor mir
haben sollte dann klickt auch hier drauf
also daneben da ist mit merchandise shop
verlinkt mit shirts und dezentral und
hier ist meine letzte action oktober zu
ende verlinkt da hatte ich sogar noch
den trecker also ich habe auf die folge
reagiert und ihr können sehen wo genau
ich hinschaue super und morgen um 12 uhr
kommt das video bezüglich meiner youtube